right now if you if you're flying
through dallas love field one of the
airports in dallas
you might encounter ornery
tsa agents you might encounter people
yelling at you to put your mask on
behind the counters
and you might encounter seven foot tall
robots who threaten to call the police
if you don't wear your mask properly
this is not the plot of some kind of
arnold schwarzenegger movie this is not
some dystopian crazy fantasy coming out
of my tin foil hat fever dreams this is
being reported right now in fortune
magazine dallas airport uses robocops to
enforce mask policy listen to the nicest
promotional
best marketing that these robots have
welcome to dallas love field airport
all ubers
lifts
taxis and rental car shuttles are
located on the lower level
to access the lower level please use an
escalator or elevator to proceed
downstairs
the first thing that strikes me about
these robots is um
i don't think we're gonna see mrs robot
anytime soon
i don't know not to be stereotypical or
anything i don't think the robots wear
shoes but if they did i think those sh
they would be a little
how do you say a little light in the
loafers uh just because it well it just
there's just something about the voice
sounds sort of very nice and calm
but they're not merely offering people
directions oh here's how you get to the
gate oh there's a delay oh this the the
robots that are being tested out here
might issue a verbal warning this is a
quote according to a fortune magazine
uh they they are looking through their
cameras to determine whether a passenger
is wearing a face mask which is still
mandated they might issue a verbal
warning if you're not which could
escalate in volume and severity if the
infraction is not corrected and the
system can also call on-site security or
the police if necessary
are
are we living in china
i know these days especially when we
look at it foreign policy it's very
fashionable to say we're here in the
land of the free thank goodness we're in
the land of the free not like those
autocratic regimes around the world like
russia or certainly not like china
that that's good
are because our
police enforcement robots speak english
our constant surveillance everywhere and
our requirement to muzzle ourselves
wherever we go
it's
it sounds a little nicer and i don't
know it's very difficult to see the
difference between the united states and
china these days increasingly it's
difficult i guess the only difference i
can point out right now
is that
our movies are a little bit gayer right
now go to superbeats.com
knowles this is the new way to start
your day and you're going to love it
super beets heart shoes they are a tasty
treat that gives you the energy you need
and that is good for you no more
afternoon coffees oh should i have my
sixth cup of coffee today none of that
no more al what about my tenth energy
drink no maybe i'll just throw a little
candy in for a quick pick me up no you
just add two delicious plant-based super
beets heart shoes to your morning
routine to promote heart-healthy energy
for your day without that caffeine crash
super beets heart chews unique
clinically researched grape seed extract
promotes heart-healthy energy and normal
blood pressure as part of a healthy
lifestyle the grape seed extract used in
super beets heart shoes has been
clinically shown to be twice as
effective as supporting normal blood
pressure as a healthy lifestyle alone do
more for your heart treat yourself with
super beats heart shoes
right now only for our listeners get up
to 45
off four or five that's a huge number
plus free shipping at superbeats.com
knowles this is their best offer
available anywhere we really appreciate
superbeats for supporting the show and
for being a great product so you should
go check it out too superbeats.com
knowles get up to 45 off
superbeats.com these statements and
products have not been evaluated by the
food and drug administration these
products are not intended to diagnose
treat cure or prevent any disease or
condition
glad you like that clip now hold up
ring the bell
subscribe get those notifications get
past the big tech sensors we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]